good afternoon everyone it's my pleasure
to be speaking at this event i would
like to thank
thermal fisher for inviting me to share
my work with you
during this pandemic virtue education
events
such as this one are very valuable
and help make quarantine a little bit
more interesting today
i'm going to talk about molecular
profiling
of hematologic malignancies by next
generation sequencing
this is the disclaimer
the prevalence of hematologic disorders
in u.s
in 2019 this data is from
leukemia lymphoma society
every three minutes one person in the
u.s
is diagnosed with a blood cancer
about 176 000 people
in the u.s are expected to be diagnosed
with leukemia
lymphoma or myeloma
new cases of leukemia lymphoma
and myeloma are expected to account for
10 of the estimated 1.7 million new
cancer cases
diagnosed in the u.s
about 61 000 people were diagnosed with
leukemia in 2019
and 14 000 people were diagnosed with
mbs
about 9600 cases of
mpn were diagnosed per year
let's look at the guidelines from nccn
the first guideline i'm going to talk
about is the acute
myeloid leukemia we call it aml
it is recommended that cytogenetics
analysis including karyotype and the
fish
to be done for molecular analysis
including c kit fleet 3 idt
and tkd mpm1 cbpa
idh12 tp53
and other mutations to be tested for the
patients
it is recommended the maximal turnaround
time
for the essay is about three to five
days for
immediately actionable mutations
including those genes in particular
for patients with fleet 3 positive
mutation
the patient has to be on the treatment
in 8 days
the next guideline is for mbs
on the left side left side
highlighted area are the genes
with the prognostic information for mds
the third guideline i'm going to talk
about is for
myeloproliferative neoplasm which is
mpn the molecular testing on the blood
for jack 2
v 617 f mutation has to be tested first
if it's negative test for c a
l r and m p l mutations for patients
with et
or mf and the jack 2 exon
12 mutations for patients with pv and
the molecular testing
using multi gene and gs panel
including those genes are recommended
there is also guidelines from cab and
ash for aml genetic testing
recommendations
it is also recommended very similar to
the ansing guideline
that include karyotype and fish and also
molecular testing for all or most of the
cases
with those mutations i just mentioned
which is very similar to the ncc
guideline for selected
selected cases the kit for core binding
factor leukemia and also for apl
we have to do the pml rara test
next i'm going to talk about genetic
abnormalities in
aml this is a very busy figure
if you look at on the left side there
are many many
genes their mutations
are commonly seen in aml patients
you can see how the percentage
represents the incidence
in the aml on the right side
side of the slide there are many many
translocations
associated with aml patients
some of the mutation coexisting
with the chance locations that will
change the prognostic
information or the treatment
the treatment associated with myeloid
biomarker testing
let's look at the disease for aml
the biomarkers include fleet 3 idh1
and 2. the s used are pcr and
nds and also the drug on the right
side of the column for cml
and apl there are bcr-801
and pm aurora chains locations
the acids include the pcr phase
karyotype ngs and also there's drugs
on the right side and the apl
used the atra for example for the pv
the jack 2 mutation analysis
is recommended to use pcr or nds method
and use the drug is also listed here
for so many different biomarkers and
tests in
these patients tests usually performed
sequentially and it takes a long time to
give results
it uses many samples instead of one
therefore ngs is the solution to reduce
number of assays turnaround time and the
sample size
if you think about the figure i showed
in the previous slide for aml there are
so many mutations
and the translocations if you do it
sequentially
it will take a really long time to get
results
the clinical utility of the multiple
biomarker testing by
ngs the detection of
multiple mutation fusions in target
genes
in a panel makes huge impact
on screening diagnosis prognosis
monitoring minimal residual disease and
predicting each individual's response to
treatment
next i'm going to show you two examples
that ngs has helped with the diagnosis
of the patients first one the indication
is 17 year old male with
arl chemo-induced pancytopenia the tests
ordered
include fish pcie able one
quantitative assay karyotype and
ngs the results showed for fish
is positive for bcr abl1 fusion
however the bcr-81 quantitative assay
did not detect either p210
or p190 for karyotype
it is qns without results because in
sufficient sample
let's look at the bcr-abl1 chance group
the typical bcr evolving fusion
transcripts
include p190 and the p210
so on the left side the blue color shows
the vcr
axons and on the right side is the
yellow color
highlighted for the able1 axons
if it's e1a2 stands for p190
so for p210 there's two forms one is
e13a2 that means the exon from
bcr e13
fused with the abl1 a2
exon and for e14a2
it's also p210 for atypical bcr able
fusion transcripts include the following
e1a3 e13 a3
e6 a2 for e19a2
that that is the rare transcript for
p230
this test is
provided by a limited of the
laboratories most of the lab
they have p190 and p210
so for this particular patient we run
the ngs
and ngs could detect bcr-801
chance groups for common and uncommon
forms
on the top is e13a2
for p210 which is a common form detected
from a different patient
on the lower part of this slide for this
particular patient we detect e13 a3
which is a rare transcript
clinical case 2 the indication is a 53
year old man with aml history
test ordered include carrier type
fish aml panel and ngs
the fish show the results negative for
aml panel
including run x1 run x1 t1
the karyotype showed in the
slide it is loss of y
added one queue deleted hq
added 21 q in 3 out of
metaphases
so what is the nds results the nds
result
showed that there is a run x1 runex t1
translocation
next we went back to re-examine the
karyotype
then we figured out it is actually a
three-way chance location
so the part of the one queue
goes to the 21q the 21q goes to
8q and 8q goes to the 1q
then we re-examine the fish results
we analyzed the additional 300 cells
3 out of 500 cells showed one fusion
which is a yellow signal
in the metaphase in the interface cell
two green
and two red signals it is confirmed
a three-way chance location involves run
x1
run x1 t1 chance location
take home messages for these two cases
mds for hematopoietic neoplasms may be
performed on peripheral blood
or marrow aspirate may detect
mutations rearrangements replacing some
phase and pcr-based analysis
turnaround time equal to or more rapid
than conventional assets
our turnaround time is about three to
five days
fish still required desirable for
monothomies large deletions
for example chromosome 507 more rapid
detection
of pmrira or other rearrangements
for case 1 ngs identifies
a rear transcript for bcr-abl1
which is e13 a3 fusion
for case 2 ngs detected a fusion
that was missed by fish or karyotype